[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
hide and seek
live
from Gabe Sanchez's YouTube channel on
hide and seek Thursday
foreign
[Music]
podcast and the Cheeto dust cue in honor
is freaking out this morning thanks for
joining us here on Gabe Sanchez's
Channel don't forget while you're here
make sure while you're here on his
channel you subscribe hit the Subscribe
button right now on Gabe Sanchez's
Channel
that is the whole purpose of playing
hide and seek we want to promote other
creators if this works if this works
meaning you guys love this show I love
this show
I love having you here every single
weekday Monday through Friday for two
full hours in the chat if you guys like
to join the chat live
we're gonna start trying to see if we
can help out some other YouTube channels
and other creators YouTube doesn't like
me
so I'm gonna show them
[__] them
so we're gonna try to build some other
um some other people's YouTube channels
out and besides the point is is that you
definitely want to come here and watch
Gabe Sanchez's content here on his
YouTube channel that's important the
what was that show how could you not
want to watch that his shorts come on
his political shorts and reels that he
does of course you want to see all that
content and you'll be able to watch it
here on Gabe Sanchez's YouTube channel
don't forget to subscribe while you're
here today on the YouTube channel and if
you found us
if you found us
uh welcome welcome if you haven't found
us yet don't worry here's what I'm gonna
do I promise if you're watching this on
my YouTube channel on a replay right now
that's because I'm gonna post it on my
YouTube channel later
that's how hide and seek I think is
gonna work same with up wire if you're
here from the up wire
and you're like why why the [__] isn't
it broadcasting where I'm usually at
we're hide and seeking on Gabe Sanchez's
YouTube channel but later on I will put
it up on my channel the Tony Michaels
podcast and the up wires Channel
so
we're gonna play hide and seek today see
how many people join us see how many
people find it's not that hard like
we're leaving bread crumbs right like I
posted this link out we said yesterday
that we were gonna do this I posted on
the Community page that we were gonna do
this so it's not a big secret
it's not a big secret
you know what is a big secret right now
exactly what Donald Trump is lying about
in the deposition with Tish James how do
you think that's going for that
[__]
[__] around find out
he is freaking out on social media today
I mean absolutely freaking out on his
fraud social over there oh my God
the guy is desperate
the guy is a caged animal the lunatic is
loose
posting all morning calling kiss James a
racist as if as if tis James is doing
this because Donald Trump is white get
the [__] out of here man
oh
I tell you what the fragility of white
males in this country I'm telling you it
is it is palpable
even when you're around one of these
[__] it is palpable
the fragility of these pasty little
white snowflakes oh my God uh one video
I watched this morning and I hope I hope
I have time to show it to you today is
[__] hilarious you know this whole
Bud Light queer beer we're not buying
rainbow beer [__] that's been going on
Kid Rock and John Rich those two [__]
bigots those pieces of garbage
those [__]
posting all of her social media oh we're
never gonna buy Bud Light I'm never
gonna drink Bud Light ever again [__]
Bud Light Bud Light can go to hell
guess what
in Nashville Tennessee that's right the
same Nashville where there's [__]
protests
and and the Republican Nazis of the
Tennessee house including Cameron Sexton
the [__] speaker expels two young
black men because they got loud while
black
that's it that's why they got expelled
have been reseeded
oh my God these Nazis walk into it every
single time
in that same Nashville that same [__]
City
Kid Rock and John Rich have bars in that
seat now I don't know if you know a lot
about Nashville Nashville is the country
music
capital of the world okay
so Kid Rock and John Rich obviously have
bars in this town because you know their
country
guess what beer they're serving at those
bars
guess what beer John rich and Kid Rock
are making boatloads of money off of
right now in Nashville
well maybe not right now but I mean like
Thursday through Sunday they make a
shitload of money
off Anheuser-Busch Michelob Ultra Bud
Light Budweiser
these [__] fake ass sons of
[__]
what a bunch of horseshit what a sack
full of [__] horse [__] Kid Rock and
John Rich are are you [__] kidding me
it only it is only they're walking skin
suits
of white male fragility
absolute [__] frauds and and I gotta
speaking of [__] queer beer
oh my God these people are I I'm telling
you you try Gabe Sanchez you're on this
channel right now and you should
subscribe right now he does his best to
parody and do satire of these
[__] but they always outdo him
they always outdo themselves you've seen
all the commercials we play here
the phony commercials the satire the
parody commercials that we play here on
the Tony Michaels podcast the Gabe
Sanchez has produced which again that's
another reason why I like his channel
I'm I'm not trying to get you to
subscribe to his channel I'm just
telling you just subscribe to his
channel that's the whole point of us
doing this today hide and seek so make
sure you subscribe but those commercials
that we play here on the show
a lot of them a lot of them are
exactly the commercial
that the Trump supporter was produced I
have a beer commercial today that you're
gonna go is this [__] real it's real
as [__]
and oh boy does it spell out the white
male fragility
and that's what this whole Donald Trump
calling Tish James the Attorney General
the state of New York who is filed the
250 million dollar lawsuit against him
which is going to absolutely [__] his
company it's gonna cause him not to be
able to do business in the state of New
York
that's what all his [__] yelling and
screaming on fraud social is this
morning it's Kid Rock shooting the beer
cans same thing it's the same exact
thing it's all [__] fake it's all
[__] no one gives a [__]
No One's Gonna Go save him he's not
gonna have a bunch of gravy seals show
up in New York to stop the deposition so
that he can't lie and perjure himself
it's the same [__] thing
it's the same [__] being outraged about
a beer printing a rainbow on the side of
their can and then turning around and
having a bar that has your [__] name
on it
in Nashville Tennessee
to serve
who knows how many thousands tens of
thousands of dollars every day when the
bar is open a Budweiser on tap cans
bottles
you fake ass [__] John rich and
Kid Rock oh my God you pieces of [__]
garbage
you're nothing but [__] phonies just
like Donald Trump's a [__] phony this
morning trying to act like tits James is
a racist you are a dumb son of a [__]
it's almost Dumber that Donald Trump
would call Tish James a racist then Kid
Rock and John Rich would hate Budweiser
or Bud Light when they're [__]
stuffing their pockets full of thousands
of dollars in profit
from Bud Light and Anheuser-Busch and
I'm sure they're excuses well we have a
contract we can't cancel that contract
what are you too woke are you too woke
just to tell the contract [__] shut
that bar down shut that bar the [__]
down Kid Rock and John Rich shut them
down close the doors you don't need that
woke ass [__]
oh man I'm telling you
no boy it's a day of winning it is a day
of winning here on the Tony Michaels
podcast it really is it really is I'm
excited about today
um also there is more there's more Rifts
going on inside manga not just the
Ridiculousness of the of the queer beer
thing because I'm going to show you this
I know I know it feels like like the
that that that ship has sailed and that
oh it doesn't matter if the yeah who
cares if they boycott Bud Light or they
listen I'm telling you I'm telling you
the more we mock them the better the
more we Mock and any anything that we
can mock them for and diminishes their
[__] their ability to anyone take
them seriously is good for democracy
it's good for democracy because John
rich and [__] Kid Rock aren't doing
this out of the because they [__]
hate Bud lighter they don't want to
drink Bud Light they're doing it for
[__] money and they're doing it for
the for the political clout give me a
[__] break if you're not doing it for
all the politics and why are you selling
Bud Light in your bar in Nashville
why shut it down close the [__] doors
you don't have to open a bar you don't
have to sell that woke ass beer if you
don't want to John rich and Kid Rock
but it's important that we mock them at
every turn every single turn
every mother [__] one of them
including when they're killing each
other I don't know if you've seen this
uh this feud between Marjorie Taylor
green uh Ali Alexander Laura Loomer and
Milo and Annapolis holy [__] they're
absolutely destroying each other online
on Telegram
it is it is absolutely delicious
and it we need to encourage this on a
mass scale inside the Republican party
let them destroy themselves just like
the Republicans are destroying
themselves in Tennessee I don't know if
you've seen this now that they've
reseeded Justin Jones and Justin Pearson
and the and and the rallies haven't
stopped the noise hasn't stopped people
are still there calling for action on
gun safety the Republicans are rushing
rushing to close their session because
they don't like loud noises
loud noises is fascist Kryptonite
and we should continue to be loud at
every every single nook and cranny of
this country doesn't matter where no
matter when be loud and be proud I'm
only one microphone you're thousands get
out there and [__] use it
and I'm telling you I'm telling you
they're running scared when the when a
legislator listen listen when a state
legislator wants to get business done
and they want to finish up their
business they really want to ram through
stuff that they can go back to their
districts to run on because they gotta
go run
I gotta go run some of these gangs gotta
go run to get their seats back so they
want plenty of hatred that they [__]
instituted into the Tennessee State ball
to go sell to their hateful constituents
right if these people really all geared
up to go vote for them based on hate
well think about this they're not going
to be able to get some of this [__]
through because they're going to be
ramming it through the the leadership
for the tennis for the Tennessee uh
house said Hey look
you guys want to pack an extra big bag
because we're going to stay a few extra
days we're not gonna go home until we
get this [__] done because we want to
close this down because the faster they
close it down the quicker they shut up
the protest and the quicker they shut up
the protests the less noise there is and
the less loud noise there is the less
fascist Kryptonite there is
that's the goal that's the point that's
their Direction they're Running Scared
we had them on their heels so don't shut
up
[__] them do not shut up keep getting
louder and louder and louder and louder
because they're going to keep going
they're not going to stop when they when
they in this legislative session in
Tennessee it won't be until the fall
that they pick up the legislative
session be damn sure they're going to be
ready to file hateful bills when that
session recommends for next year
to do their budget in Tennessee I'm
telling you they're going to have the
hate bills ready ready to go and they're
going to be pumping it through
speaking a hateful crazy [__] bills
at yesterday in the Missouri Senate
there's a Missouri state senator this
[__] scumbag yesterday said 12 year
old girls should get married because
they stay married that's what he said I
mean not in so many words but that's
what the [__] he said
that 12 year old let's listen listen to
listen to me 12 year old girls should be
allowed through their parental consent
to get married because when a 12 year
old girl gets married she stays married
for the rest of her life
that is the argument for marrying little
children these Republicans are
pedophiles these Republicans are [__]
groomers these Republicans are [__]
scummy ass Nazis that's what they are
that's what they're trying to do listen
no there is there is no evidence
anywhere a mass drag queenings killing
and murdering
hundreds of people plenty of evidence of
mass shootings they won't do anything on
guns but they must they must stop
the ability of men men dressing up in a
in a woman's clothing and wigs and
makeup and dancing around because
they're grooming children all the while
they're wanting to marry the same people
saying this or wanting to marry 12 year
olds off
with parental consent do you see where
everything hinges
in this debate between transgenderism
and and drag queens
it all hinges on the parental consent
folks I've been telling you this
for over a year it's the parental
consent that they're going after that's
what they want they want their hands on
your consent of your children
that's their goal
we had Jess Piper on uh several weeks
ago talking about this
now I know I know Jess Piper made made
the argument that vouchers and charter
schools are direction for child labor
what do you think child labor is is
taking away your consent
to make sure that your child ends up in
the workforce get the [__] out listen
folks
this is all projection from the gqp
every single bit of it from the real
America First Nazi party
when a state senator in Missouri
testifies in a committee this isn't like
he was whispering in a restaurant and
someone recorded it he set it into a
microphone proudly I'll show you the
tape
the tape is it a tape or is it a clip
damn what is this 1990
I'll show you the tape like I got a VHS
ready to go or some [__] what the [__]
I'll show you the clip
oh damn I'm telling you it is a good day
it is a good day in this country to
fight this political battle there is no
better ammunition that is going to be
given to us than the by
the failing Republican party themselves
no better evidence and the and this
morning right now rest assured right now
the Cheeto dust q and honors orange face
paint is melting off his face from all
the sweat
with Tish James staring him down asking
him question after question after
question after question after question
we have real real Warriors in this fight
Alvin brags not to be [__] with he
told Jim Jordan hey [__] you want to
obstruct [__] around and find out tis
James ah Donald Trump wanted to [__]
around and commit fraud in the state of
New York [__] around and find out Jack
Smith I bet I bet his [__] round and
find out phase is in full swing
as well as Fanny Willis in Georgia why
do you think that Cheeto does q and
honor and all these fragile white men
are losing their minds this morning
the exposure of their projection is
coming and it will keep coming and we
will pile it on and pile it on and pile
it on and pile it on because that's what
we do folks I I know I know I told you
the other day that we're selling a new
brand of liberalism and that's what this
is
this brand of liberalism is not weak
it's not puny we don't hide behind
elitism or academics or data or polls
[__] you this new brand of liberalism we
stand and we stand strong on principle
that's what we do Freedom Liberty rights
Equity equality that's right Dei and CRT
[__] were woke as [__] here
and we see it as strength
not his weakness
so get used to it you you [__] you
[__] fascist get used to it because
we ain't going nowhere
and we're gonna keep being loud and
proud and we're gonna come right at you
right at you and mock the [__] out of
you
will not get away with your projection
you will not get away with your Dirty
Deeds you will not get away with your
hypocrisy you will not get a get away
with your pedophilia we will point it
out and we will show it
we are not scared
we are not scared to offend anyone we
are not scared to be offended
this new brand of liberalism is coming
for you fascist it's coming hard trust
me I know
this microphone might be the lead
it just damn well might be
so be warned be warned because we're
gonna be loud
and those loud noises those loud liberal
noises
are the fascist Kryptonite they hate it
all they hate it
they hate the truth
they hate it and you know what you know
I'm also scared of it this new brand of
liberalism you know what else they're
scared of with this
they're scared of you they're scared
that you will come here every single day
and listen to this new brand of
liberalism that is not tied to Academia
that it's not tied to elitism
that it's not tied to data and polls
that you don't you don't need to know a
whole and cycle pile of encyclopedia's
worth of information to understand
certain liberal ideas of freedom and
liberty like stay the [__] out of my
life
don't tell me who I can love don't tell
me who I can [__] don't tell me what I
can wear what hair my color my hair what
color my hair is don't tell me what is
woke and what is not don't tell me what
I should and shouldn't be doing what
religion I shouldn't shouldn't be
we don't have to go broke because of
medical bills in this country
if Elon Musk can afford to lose 30
billion dollars on Twitter he can afford
to cough up the money
in taxes so we can do things like make
sure people don't go broke because of
medical bills make sure make sure that
children start schooling three instead
of five that way the parents don't have
to afford those two extra years of
daycare and I don't know it might be
good for our citizen to read to be smart
instead of dumb asses like we have some
of these megalodites it's obvious our
education system has been failing us
oh you know what else you know what else
we can do speaking of Education we could
make sure people get higher education
After High School tech school college
Career Training whatever it may be and
not have to be saddled to debt for the
rest of their [__] lives speaking on
the rest of their lives it would be nice
if folks in this country could afford to
live
to have a home to own a home maybe maybe
even get a mortgage for crying out loud
might be nice in this country for more
people to settle down in their lives
after they've went through affordable
schooling at the secondary level
all the new liberalism and why they're
afraid why they're afraid does these
ideas sound radical to you do they sound
radical when I say them do they sound
radical how I say them well I think not
and that's why they're terrified
that's why they're terrified they're
terrified I mean even even the haters in
the chat here even the haters in the
chat here eventually trust me even even
the worst of the worst of them
eventually will say things like this out
in public yeah you heard of this Tony
Michael's gay yeah well I mean I don't
like Tony [__] Tony but you know I agree
with that 30 40 percent of what he says
we're getting there folks
we're getting there and I'm telling you
we just can't stop we just have to keep
pounding the drum and keep going and
keep pushing
we'll get there
we'll get there fascism will crawl back
underneath its Rock and I'm gonna make
sure of it and Gabe Sanchez is gonna
make sure of it too he's coming up I'm
telling you he's coming up
he's coming in hot
so make sure you subscribe to Gabe
Sanchez's YouTube channel right now
we're broadcasting live from his channel
and almost everyone our audience is
almost as big as it normally is everyone
found us hide and seek Thursday is a
success
it is a success so I I hope I hope you
support Gabe Sanchez here on his YouTube
channel I hope you watch his content
watch his videos take them seriously to
to consume them share them around share
this Channel with your friends and on
social media and and in real life
because we're trying to support content
creators because that's what we have to
have our microphones every single one of
them have to be Amplified not just mine
not just gays but yours as well
so turn up the volume turn up the volume
it's hide and seek Thursday everyone
stick around don't go anywhere we'll be
right back right after this break
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day I'm recurring
and it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the Tony
Michaels podcast here on Gabe Sanchez's
YouTube channel don't forget right now
right now if you have not
subscribe to gameview game Sanchez
YouTube channel do that right now go
down below and click subscribe click the
like button go share it with two or
three friends tell them to subscribe and
share the share the broadcast as well
we're trying to support Gabe Sanchez
today on hide and seek Thursday I know
maybe we'll start doing hide and seek
Thursday like once a month or something
and we'll find a channel we'll go over
what do you guys think you guys I don't
know I I think you guys like this
everyone's here seems like everybody's
here today
everybody everybody
everybody's here today
um we're still broadcasting on Facebook
and twitch so if you're out there and
we're on Twitter as well so if you're if
you're watching on those platforms
please please do us a favor and come
over to YouTube for just a second you
can go back to your other broadcast if
you like to watch on Facebook go over go
over to YouTube and subscribe to Gabe
Gabe Sanchez's YouTube channel
you'll find the link
on Twitter you can just go and type in I
am Gabe Sanchez
into YouTube and it'll bring you to his
channel you will see
you will see
the the line broadcast there and give
him a like and share the broadcast
we're gonna have Gabe Sanchez come in
here in just a minute let's see uh let's
see do you guys like this uh hide and
see let's see the peekaboo peek of maybe
we call it like peek-a-boo Thursday
peek-a-boo Thursdays hide and seek I
don't know what do you think here's
here's how the idea became about last
month
I may have got suspended for seven days
I know some [__] I said I don't know you
know you know how it happens I say stuff
YouTube doesn't like it I appeal they
still don't like it so they keep me
suspended for seven days on my channel
but we had already been broadcasting
from the up wires Channel I wasn't band
evading I had already been broadcasting
over there so you know I hope that I
didn't break terms of service anyways
the point is this is that
um all of you follow us over to the up
wires Channel and I was like oh my God
our audience because I I say to you all
the time you're the best audience in the
world and you are and you prove it time
and time and time again today is proof
right now right here it's proof
that you are the best audience in the
world you you showed up on a totally
different Channel with a totally
different link you found us that means
you're listening that means you're
paying attention and it's important
these things are important to pay
attention to and I know some of the some
of the stuff we cover and some of the
stuff we we talk about seems minute
and it seems so small in the grand
scheme of things but all these things
are interconnected they really are and
we have to stay on top of the right wing
in their narrative and their messaging
and their [__] just like the Bud
Light thing we're gonna mock the [__]
out of them today so if you if you're
excited to watch a bunch of right
Wingers like Kid Rock and John Rich get
absolutely mocked and destroyed uh for
for hating on rainbows that are printed
on Bud Light games boy are you in the
right place don't go anywhere because
we're going to show you this video today
I'm gonna show it to you
I guess got some got some bidges to show
you and boy do I have oh my God I don't
know who this [__] idiot is
but that there's some kind of Nazi beer
that they're selling now because of the
oh there's rainbows on beer so we need
to have Nazi beer they're selling it for
twenty dollars a six pack I'm not
kidding you a six pack of this Nazi beer
costs 20 bucks
it ain't no wonder the right wing
[__] Cashes in on these grips so much
these people are [__] dumb who in the
[__] who who in the [__] in their right
mind would pay twenty dollars for any
six pack of beer
any of it I mean Gabe Sanchez what is
the most that you have ever paid for a
six pack of beer what's the most you
think you've ever paid to your own
channel yeah thank you thank you thank
you uh how much have I paid man uh six
pack
I'm trying to think like probably the
most would be like uh like a local
Brewery right and if it was them then
maybe it's just like craft beer yeah
yeah yeah so like maybe like
really honestly that's the reason why I
like to drink natural light is because
you can buy like a 30 a 30 pack for like
for like eight bucks still I mean like
inflation goes up and the cost of
natural light always goes down for some
reason yeah well you know it's one of
those things where also you're like uh I
can always rely on this thing to never
go up in price you know right it'll
always stay stay where it's at it's like
you know
um
uh what was the [__] what was the
product when inflation was going up
everyone's like oh it was the the the
Arizona Iced Tea Always 99 Cents right
never goes above that right and this is
one of those things too where it's like
Natty light or anything else you're like
yep price is the same I can always rely
on it I I'm gonna be able to buy a a
natural light for nothing yeah nothing I
mean it's cheaper than water really I
mean it's mostly water but it's mostly
water I mean you're hydrating while
dehydrating it's a great combo you know
it's like it's like the yin and yang of
drinking and you get to get a little
wasted in the meantime yeah man do I
have you and I don't know if you've seen
this I have I have this
commercial I know oh my God this is okay
I just want to say this this is why I
cannot do parody commercials anymore
really I know that's what I was telling
the audience because [__] I saw this
last night and I was like this is a joke
right and and I was like and I went to
the website and I looked it up and I was
like yeah this is definitely not a joke
is a real thing it's hilarious it's
hilarious I'm I'm gonna give the guy
credit like he wasn't trying to write
comedy but and he walked into it
you're like oh man we're gonna own the
libs and then again we've talked I mean
just this week we I brought it up before
it was like they the right tries to own
the lips and then face plant face plant
face plant every time he's playing well
I mean I'm gonna show you some face
planning of Kid Rock and John rich on
this beer thing everyone is in the chat
Gary B says 12 bucks is the most he's
paid yeah uh uh Roderick says 15. uh
Betty Ann on Facebook says 12 bucks in
Canada yeah I feel like that's the eight
bucks I mean this is kind of the
consensus like eight to twelve bucks
right and I think I feel like the most
I've paid has been like when I've gone
to a brewery and I was like oh yeah I'll
get I like the little like the flight
that I did so I'm gonna buy that beer
and then I pay 12 bucks or whatever you
know and that's how it is uh
here's another one YouTube Maria it says
I buy uh kombucha kombucha it's 12 hours
a six-pack but it's 8.3 so like wow it
might be 12 bucks right it might be 12
bucks but then she gets heavy yeah
I'm not a kombucha person but I remember
when kombucha really hit the market hard
they because it had like 0.5 or 1
alcohol because of the fermentation you
know they were asking to be like hey can
I see your ID right and some of these
kombuchas that were made when I live in
San Francisco some of them and again I'm
not a kombucha drinker but I worked with
people who did really love kombucha and
there were times at little little like
markets that we would go to uh like a
corner store that they would be like oh
I need to see your ID because of the
alcohol content that's produced from the
fermentation what's what's the one
what's the one that's um
it is it's high in content but it's an
energy drink it's got a lot of caffeine
in it what what the hell is that the
yeah people were [__] like dying of
alcohol poisoning and [__] well there a
lot of people were blacking out there
was like the Four Loco challenge where
you would try to drink as many as you
could just see where the night goes I
mean it was pretty great like on College
when I was at college that was my
birthday that I felt that I mean I drank
Jager not for Loco but that's the way I
felt like I blacked down like [__] and I
because did you know this that you don't
actually lose your memories it's just
your your brain can't fully function on
that much alcohol so it's not forming
memories so it's not recording in other
words did you know okay so you just
don't have a memory card in the slot
right you're like I pushed the button
right it's like it's like if we started
the broadcast here and but didn't push
start broadcast yeah nothing's recording
and Justice
same way on my birthday same way on Four
Loco
I don't know if you knew that but uh
here is let me show you this
um I'm not gonna show you the parody
commercial first I want to save that
yeah yeah that's [__] hilarious
um this is a tick tock here we're gonna
go to tick tock
um for this video here let me see if I
can get it going hey all I'm downtown
Nashville on Broadway I'm not I'm not as
used to this so give me just a minute
here ah there we go okay all right fine
all right here's here's a tick tock now
this guy his name is Father Nathan Monk
he's in Nashville and let's listen to uh
listen to this video this is [__]
hilarious hey y'all I'm downtown
Nashville on Broadway right out in front
of Kid Rock's joint down here now he's
just made a big stink pretending like
he's all kinds of outraged about the
fact that transgender people exist and
said that he has ended his relationship
with Anheuser-Busch Budweiser because of
the fact that they support lgbtq people
well we're about to go inside and see if
they have Budweiser or if he's just
participating in selective outrage
Riviera
so I I had to actually back this up a
couple times on this Tick Tock because
he said Big and Rich but I thought he
said bigot and Rich I mean you know
aren't they the same though around it
could be I was like I just don't I had
to make sure I just don't see it being
the other way I don't see a big enrich
I see a big and rich being the likely
possibility big it I mean look we hear
what we want to hear because it's
probably true to what they said right
well and you know I appreciate this guy
going to Nashville to make it it sounds
like he's from Nashville yeah he said
he's from yeah he's he's from that's
he's born well and I think at the end of
the video he says that he's like look
the reason it's so important is because
I'm from here right well and he said in
the beginning of the video he said y'all
right yeah yeah I mean if that's that
you're like any y'all I know if he
wasn't if he wasn't from a certain Area
country say hey you guys or hey guys he
said y'all
hey you guys he said y'all folks all
right let's listen
that's a poster of him right there he
also has claimed to end his relationship
with Anheuser-Busch because oh no they
support the lgbtq community let's go
find out if that's true as well or if he
is also just participating in selective
outbreak
oh look there
let's look there look at all those beers
that are owned by the one company oh my
God right
about what a bunch of has been washed up
recording artists from the 90s and I
don't except for the fact that I grew up
in this town Nashville is my City
Tennessee is my fault and these guys
aren't even from here and they're
wanting you to believe that that is what
Nashville is but it's not Nashville is
but I'd love to show you
[Music]
listen to
I see them blue
and I think to myself
[Music]
[Applause]
family
foreign
[Music]
and that is Nashville folks as I can
tell you I I've been in Nashville a
couple times and every time I've gone
both times it's been awesome right I
went there for just to hang I went there
for a bachelor party uh it was a ton of
fun went downtown we just bar hopped
around did karaoke sang drank met people
wait wait you can sing you can sing I
don't know I'm okay I'm okay I'm no Tony
Michaels I know I'm no regular Wednesday
night yeah you're drinking karaoke
singing I did have like um I don't know
is it three or four shots of Jager I
thought I was gonna I thought it was
gonna be I thought it was gonna I
thought it was gonna be several weeks
before I was gonna be able to drink
Jaeger again I will admit but I yeah
well you know what they say hair of the
dog right now you gotta get it in yeah
no no I I think I think Nashville is a
great place I want to go to Nashville
this year just and the reason why is
because the historic moment that has
been made in Nashville and I'm not
talking about the video we just saw
where Kid Rock and John Rich are rich
are carp are bigoted I mean I don't know
I would say it is pretty historic and
historic in the way that the letter the
right own themselves right well right I
mean if you if you count every every
time they do it I mean it does also it
could be historical you know if the ATF
were called to Kid Rock's estate and you
know who knows what kind of weapons he
has there right right that could be
right but but you know the the thing
that I think is historic about Nashville
is what just happened this last weekend
this week where uh Cameron Sexton who
who resides in Nashville but he pretends
to live somewhere else because he loves
Nashville because Nashville is the
liberal city right in Tennessee right
and he wants to take advantage of all
the blue the blue city right because he
likes that that because it's not a
[__] [__] hole he wants to take
advantage of it so he's carpet bagging
and and stealing a Per Diem from from
the state because he doesn't actually
live in the district that he has his
constituents in so there's that sound
why does that sound so familiar it's a
republic it's a republican yeah yeah got
it got it even even it's almost even in
your home state yeah Josh Hawley yeah
Josh Hawley actually had to come rent a
house in the capital city of Jefferson
City yeah
um to be attorney general like he had a
rented he didn't live there he just had
to rent it but here's the thing here's
the thing is because we have that story
right and Cameron sex is the same one
who who sought to expel who suspended
the rules on the Tennessee house floor
to play a video to bring a motion to
expel to black men because they were
loud while being black
as legislators right and he expels those
two black members not only did he do
that they didn't expel the white woman
which she stood in solidarity with those
two black men Justin represented Justin
Jones and representative Justin Pearson
from Memphis and Justin Jones is from
Nashville he represents part of
Nashville
the craziest part to me is within days
within days yeah Justin Jones marches
from the city from the council
where they voted 36 to nothing to
reinstate him to his seat and he walks
from the council to the Capitol with
hundreds of protesters stands on the
capitol steps to be sworn in
only for Cameron Sexton and Republican
party just like John rich and Kid Rock
are being are face planting in Nashville
Cameron Sexton face planted in Nashville
and yesterday it happened again it
happened again yesterday where Justin
Pearson of Memphis in a unanimous vote
gets reseeded to his seat that he was
stripped up because he was loud while
black mm-hmm
when they were trying to do anything
while the legislator was in session to
get Republicans to do something red flag
background checks any just the
acknowledgment right I mean just just
you know it
we've come to a point where asking
Republicans do the bare minimum which is
hey a bunch of people died can you at
least acknowledge and care enough to do
something even if you want to [__]
sugarcoat something and not do it
whatever it might be just just show us
that you have some sense of empathy or
some sense of care for another person
especially as Republicans who claim I'm
a Christian you can trust me I will I
love you I love my neighbor and then you
find out no they could say uh you can go
kick rocks I don't care [__] about you
right you're not paying me money I only
love the Anna Ray anyone who wants to
Lobby me and I've got a price tag on the
back of my jacket right now there's a
number there if you agree to it or more
I will happily tell these victims to go
get [__] and I will expel these two
black men from the chambers of our our
local uh legislative or legislator
to prove that I'm the white guy and I've
got all the power and as we learned
again face plant boom four or five days
later we're finding that both of these
guys come back from expulsion to say did
you guys learn your lesson yet um like
you literally just just literally asking
it he's like so what did we learn from
this experience huh what did we learn
what have we learned you guys are bigots
and you're [__] idiots what have we
learn it's like Justin Jones getting
down on his knees talking to a little
kid what I know what did you learn from
your mistakes honey okay so what are we
gonna do next time guys what are we
gonna do oh my God We're not gonna do
this again because what happens you
unanimously voted back in so we know
that we're [__] safe try it again I
[__] dare you because that's the
reality too both of them coming back in
strongly right unanimous vote to get
reinstated uh after expulsion they know
they're [__] they they are safe no
matter what happens so if if Cameron
Sexton wants to pull this [__] again I
say goodbye
get your [__] shovel out and dig your
grave let's do it I'm not gonna stop you
[__] you keep going buddy try it again I
think it was I think it was Rachel
bittickoffer uh who said that Cameron
Sexton and the Tennessee Republicans
created the A Little Rock situation for
them right a modern day Little Rock
situation you know and so I I would
completely agree you know it they they
their racism and their bigotry was on
full display right and they didn't get
what they wanted and there the fascism
you know of what they were trying to do
you know I I think the most stunning
thing about it is that Cameron Sexton
and Tennessee Republicans
had no had no foresight in the backlash
of what they were about to do they never
do they were like we're gonna get we're
going to get rid of these uppity boys
and they're gonna be gone and everyone's
gonna
listen they're gonna love us and we're
gonna be national heroes and the ACT
actually the opposite happened right
like yeah I mean they didn't have the
foresight to even see that that was the
political ramifications of what they
were about to do but they never do
[__] just prices gas prices I did
that that [__] backfired inflation
five percent down cooling over the the
wow wow wow you with your data impact
he's easy on the truth there sonny but I
mean look I'm just saying that's why I
say and I know it feels like what like
what does what does Justin Jones and
Justin Pearson being expelled from the
Tennessee house by Cameron Sexton a
bunch of bigoted white dudes who are who
represent the Republican caucus because
they're loud wild black what does that
have to do with this Bud lightning it
has everything to do with it because
this is their total mindset they have
they have no other [__] gear no other
mode that owned the libs that's it
that's it full stop they have no other
mode I mean that's why Missouri three in
Missouri they defunded libraries every
single [__] penny what is crazy about
this Missouri Library Thing
is they're having to go through and
figure out what libraries are going to
not exist anymore because they're not
going to get State funding they're only
going to rely on property tax because in
the state of Missouri as in Most states
public libraries are partially funded by
State dollars partially funded by
property tax right what's crazy is in
the big bigger cities the Bluer areas
where property values are higher and
there's more properties right so there's
more people paying per parcel in those
areas there's more tax dollars that are
that are put into libraries through
property tax not State funding which
means that that the libraries that are
in the bigger areas the bigger blue
democrat-run areas that that those are
the ones that are not going to be shut
down the one the libraries that I mean
shut down are the rural libraries the
smaller communities where sometimes
that's their only access to the outside
world they don't have any other access
to the outside world and what I mean by
that is they may not have high-speed
internet but in that Library they may
not have access to email but in that
Library if they don't have high speed
internet I mean it may be their only
digital access to that world I mean in
some ways you could consider these
libraries as the digital Oasis right
right in many of these areas the only
place to connect with the outside world
that isn't a landline phone right is the
library but but see that's the problem
with these Republicans is they they're
so foresighted because it's all on the
libs that they don't understand that the
library is really more of a digital Hub
than a hub for books they're terrified I
mean they're almost as scared of books
as they are drag queens oh I mean these
Mass bookings I tell you what Gabe's
inches these Mass bookings are leaving
are leaving Republicans knowing the
truth everywhere and it's really
devastating
there is a trail of bodies Left Behind
these books I mean Pages thrown book
covers slash right right bodies
high-powered books right but by the war
Mighty librarian brings up a point she
says the constitution in Missouri says
Library will be funded so it'll be
interesting to see and most likely will
be a challenge in the courts well that's
that's why they defunded them okay so so
what happened was is the Missouri
legislator wanted to stick their hands
into the library's business and what I
mean by that is they wanted to tell
these libraries what books they couldn't
couldn't have on the shelves so the
Librarians took to the courts and said
no you can't you you don't have any
right to tell us what we're going to put
in here and the legisl the the the
people who were trying to force them to
do this said no we do because we give
you funding so that's where they said
well fine if we don't get anything to
say in it will not fund you we just
won't give you a single nickel that's
where this came down right that's where
they're at so we'll see we'll see who
wins out here is it I don't know the
public the people listen I know a lot of
people the only way they can afford to
watch movies is to go to the library and
rent them through their Public Library
through DVDs like literally that's the
only way they can afford to watch movies
they don't have have Netflix they don't
have Hulu they don't have Disney they
don't have they don't have all these
streaming services or cable or satellite
the only way that they get to watch some
of these movies is through the public
library and I don't know people know
that but your Public Library they don't
rent as long as you got a library card
and now a lot of them limit how many but
you can go rent movies for free for free
it doesn't cost you a thing I've got
I've got an app on my phone that
connects with uh it's a it's a central
hub for all the libraries I believe in
the United States and you can go in and
you register and you're like all right
this is where I'm registered as my
library and here's my library card so
they look you up in the system and from
my phone I can say great I want to rent
this book and I can get the digital like
Kindle version of that book I could do
it from my Kindle as well
um and it's it's an amazing thing I can
look on the phone and be like oh you
know what there's a there's a there's a
wait list for that book or there's a
waitlist for whatever that piece of
content is and I can wait on it I can
add myself to it right the I mean
amazing technology allows you to have
access to these things without having to
leave your home without it to actually
go to the library because you can go to
the library website sign up get your
card and then you can get it in the mail
you use this app you log in you can go
to the actual the actual Library website
as well but you can use this one app
that I have I think it's called Uh Libby
or something like that and yeah
Elizabeth is saying Libby app yeah
that's the one yeah that's the one that
I have and so you use that and you're
like great I now can have access to the
Kindle version of these books without
having to go into the library well and
here's here's the thing too is that
um a lot of people don't even know that
these services are at what services the
library because they got a lot of
services at the library not just not
just books Again movies
um at newspapers I mean if you can't
afford newspaper subscriptions but you
want to read the newspaper you can go
read the news at at the library I mean
the library is a physical Google right
well right and Ben says it best here he
says on YouTube he says libraries belong
to the people and the reason why they
belong to the people is because they're
um what's the word Public public is that
is that the word it's publicly funded so
it means our tax dollars pay for that
information to be organized in a way
that we can access it for no charge that
we have an easy access that I don't know
like I don't know maybe and these that
sounds pretty well while I did it's kind
of woke
listen libraries public libraries are so
popular in in rural Missouri that they
set up um I forget exactly what they're
called but they're called like locks
lock box libraries because not every
Community because libraries cost money
it's a building there's people got to be
in there they're called Librarians
there's just [__] it happens right so
regionally in Missouri a lot of these
communities don't even have libraries
but they have what they call I think
it's called the lock box Library where
you have an app and it's just like a
digital lock box like the ones that you
see at an airport so you would go on the
App rent it and it would go to the locks
lock box in your community instead of
having like mobile libraries like they
used to have they have these lock boxes
and then you go you scan your code the
lock box opens you pull your material
out you return the material that you had
so if you got books or movies or
whatever and that is giving access to
those libraries in those very small
rural communities in Missouri yes right
guess what's going to happen when they
don't have funding from the state guess
what's going to happen I don't know
what's gonna happen I did they're not
gonna have those they're not gonna have
those Mighty librarian are are are our
library librarian on staff on staff here
at the Tony Michaels podcast she says
you can get ebooks devices all sorts of
things our libraries have Zoo tickets
what yeah listen if they have events
they I mean I'm telling you it's almost
like they want people to read
I know these are radical woke ideas no
they won't they want people to know
truth they want people to read fiction
and non-fiction they want people to be
well well versed in worldly views yeah
I'm telling you man information is a
[__] but here's the thing here's
the thing is that the reason why they
don't want this is because they're
terrifying that people will know the
truth like this whole [__] beer thing
because we just watched the truth about
John Rich a bigoted and Rich and Kid
Rock and we've seen it before right kid
right wearing a Coors jacket and let
them know the history right Coors Coors
is gayer than Bud Light I mean like if
we had to have the 10 gayest beers you
know like their list would be really
[__] up yeah right surprise those
Rockies aren't a rainbow you know right
exactly exactly well I think they have
been before in the past well I think I
think I think I've only known them as
blue but they might have something well
I think Coors Light printed those cans
in Denver for for Pride with pride
colors on the cans for Denver because
again the mountain but what I'm saying
is like you know how when it's cold the
the Rockies turn blue oh well I yeah no
I don't know if yeah you're talking
about the special can yeah yeah see I'm
more offended that Coors is like look
our can tells you when it's cold and
it's got rainbows on It come on man no I
know when the cans cold I [__] pick
it up no I don't know man but the can
tells me when it's really cool oh Jesus
correct and that's when I know that's
when I know I just crack it open and go
you and your Coors
I don't drink at all I'm from the
Midwest
you can hate on me all you want but I
think it tastes like [__] I don't know I
just really well yeah I'm you would you
would say you would rather have Keystone
or Natty light over of course not
Keystone definitely not natural light
definitely but like or Michelob I mean I
like Michelob Michelob no man michelobs
for me one more on the list I mean
that's like that's like the bougiest
beer I drink yeah Michelob 64. you're
watching your cows on that one well
sometimes I haven't drank beer in a long
time the reason why is I get
way too hungover on beer so and that's
me not you know knowing that I get hung
over yeah right
speaking speaking of getting hung over
and face planting on beer
let's get to this parody commercial I
want to show you this
um this guy really Brands Bud Light
really well in the commercial that's a
great shot great shot I was like
baseball beer right before before we
watched this
if you want to watch real parody and
satire intentional parodying Center make
sure right now that you subscribe to
Gabe Sanchez's YouTube channel that's
where we're broadcasting live and you'll
be able to watch all the all the famous
commercials you see here on the Tony
Michaels podcast you'll be able to watch
those and more you'll be able to watch
what was that every single week here on
here on Gage Sanchez's Channel when he
releases it publicly so make sure to
subscribe and click the Bell
notification right now while you're on
his YouTube channel we're playing hide
and seek Thursdays they all found us
every [__] yes that was awesome of
our audience I was like I don't know how
it's gonna turn out but then I was
watching I was watching from the back
end in the in the in the studio and I
was like oh okay people are in here it's
great they came they turned out and I
think it's because of this video really
because Gabe Sanchez as good as videos
as you make I know I don't know that
you'll ever be able to outdo this dude
again when I saw this last night I was
like well I [__] quit dude right like
I just right I saw I saw it last night
and I and the first Instagram was like
this can't be real and then like 15
seconds and I was like [__] this is real
damn it God damn it it's and it's oh my
God it oozes of this white male
fragility that I was talking about
earlier making a problem because what it
is is is Republicans they're outraged
they're fake outrage they make a problem
and then they have to introduce a
solution which is you pay 19.99 for a
six pack and watch a guy
kind of pathetically tell you how these
beers are woke I guess his beer is
better I guess well let's let's watch
it's less than a minute so let's let's
take a listen here
to the unintentional parody of manga
America's been drinking beer from a
company that doesn't even know which
restroom to use oh my God
that's why I creating conservative dads
Ultra right 100 woke free beer you heard
that right yeah
this beer is all white man it's all like
it's so white like I can see through it
I couldn't I couldn't make it through
the whole thing okay so first off first
off this goes to the heart of what we've
talked about before
these These people aren't really scared
of what's printed on the can and I'm
gonna prove to that you that here just
in a bit when he when he takes a
baseball bat to a Bud Light can I'm
gonna prove to you that it's not about
what's printed on the can because they
can't even find the cans that they're
pissed off about right even for this
commercial I'm serious even for this
commercial they can't even find the cans
that they're pissed off about here's the
thing here's the thing is this goes to
the heart of these guys are so terrified
if they go to a bar and they see a
beautiful woman
in the bar and they want to hit on her
or creep on her or be rapey with her you
know how these get you know how this guy
is come on he's like 100 woke free all
right beer
I don't put anything in women's drinks
you know that kind of [__] okay here's
his fear and I I I'm starting to see
where this is playing out here it's
becoming clear these these [__]
fragile white men are in a bar right and
they look across the room there's a
beautiful oh man she's she must be 5 10
5 11. oh sexy woman got beautiful
clothes on showing her shoulders oh my
God no short shoulders
gorgeous gorgeous that is too
pornographic for me now
he notices that she's drinking
a Bud Light Gabe Sanchez now now he
starts to think whoa whoa whoa that Bud
Light that turns you trans
and he just gets all kinds of confused
and he is wondering to himself because
he's so focused on bathrooms I can't
believe that he they tee off in this
commercial about wieners about genitalia
immediately they're like they don't even
know what bathroom to go into and the
genitalias and stuff literally that is
their first focus is on genitalia in
bathrooms you actually know how you can
solve this whole problem right away you
make unisex bathrooms yeah yeah right
look look you don't have to have a bunch
of stalls or urinals or whatever make
unisex bathrooms you walk in door
there's a toilet you can [__] in privacy
you have to worry about other people
going who's doing that right you don't
have to make weird sounds or whatever
you know wait wait wait wait wait wait
let's say you're in the bathroom right
you're taking a [__] someone's making a
[__] next to you aren't you encouraging
them like yeah get it out man I mean
sometimes sometimes people sometimes
people might have anxiety and they're
like I don't want to next to someone
right somebody might be like I I forgot
what it was I was watching a show or a
movie and somebody was in the bathroom
with another guy and they farted and
then the guy looks over he's like that's
the whole point and I was like oh yeah
that's a good point but like there's
there's spots um
like in San Francisco there's a bar that
I would usually go to that had uh unisex
bathrooms right it just had a trough
where you would wash your hands but then
unisex bathroom you go in lock the door
boom done like you'd have to worry about
it but the funny thing is the first time
I ever went there they had
um they have uh like uh vents on the
side right you know
and I walked in and I heard this like ah
oh God uh like I heard these sounds and
I was like I was like holy [__]
someone's having sex are they banging in
the back like someone's having sex in
the bathroom dude this is nuts well I
mean you know if you're gonna do it in
private at a bar right all right so I
was like oh my God so like I you know
left washed my hands went to the the
table I was at and I was like you ran
away I was like oh my God
like I was like holy [__] it I was like
guys I'm pretty sure someone's banging
in the bathroom over there and they're
like and my friend was like no way and
the a girl that we were she's like well
I gotta go to the bathroom I'll see she
goes over and of course I didn't tell
her which which door I went into right
so she went over there she's like I
heard it too and I was like which one
she's like oh I went over to the corner
and I was like oh I was on this end and
I was like unless there's somebody
[__] real loud in here it's got to be
something else what I found out was they
were bringing in audio as like a gag
like it's just something they did at the
bar and they would play it through the
event so it would go through and it
sounds like someone was having sex
having sex that's hilarious [__]
awesome
Dar is here she says just [__] at home
Hey listen sometimes you go to the bar
and you might eat some bar food and then
you're drinking
and you just you can't make it home you
just can't make it home that sometimes
you know nature does its thing but let's
watch nature do its thing with this dumb
[__] let's let's wait what is it what
does his bracelet say
um I'm closet Freedom no freedom freedom
speaks up oh my god oh oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah that that's his that's his
organization I went to this guy's a
Twitter page and looked at his page his
his page is more fragile than his
commercial let's let's let's let's watch
as conservatives we're constantly
getting hit in the face left and right
by the woke mind virus but the last
place we wanted watch him throw this
ball this is [__] terrible if you
know which bathroom what a [__] cut
can't even throw a baseball and then
watch how and then and then watch him as
he's about to hit this beer can The
Stance and the pivoting of his foot he
he totally knows how to he totally knows
how to sports he's like I've bought this
baseball cap from the from the store
right I I also got this wooden stick
yeah they called it a bat I bet you this
bat was made not in America I I would
it's probably not an American-made bat
yeah and it's probably a chinese-made
bat because we know that Trump likes
American-made bats I mean because he
said American made bats like
American-made bats like 100 times right
that's why he it was an American-made
bed I wasn't threatening Elvin Bragg it
was American-made bat but I was
promoting right American made bats in
the in with the American I never saw the
photo when I posted the article on true
social so I can't be held liable for
that right nope nope it's not it's not
threats not at all let's watch let's
watch let's see if you get a threat kind
of a vibe from this America made
baseball bat I throw to use you know
what beer you should be drinking stop
giving money to woke corporations to
hate our values
okay here we go so I want to point out
that he does a really good job I mean
Bud light's huge right it's the whole
[__] brain and it's a tall boy so
it's like oh right you're not going for
the little little 12 ounce well he do
you think he could swing and hit a 12
ounce can I don't know I mean
you know I wouldn't here's the thing
what I will say is like you think that
he would be pretty good at nailing a
small Target considering that he's got
to focus on one
down there all the time yeah you know I
figure like yeah he's got to deal with
something small down there and so aim is
probably
got to be pretty good with right why I
want to point something out here this
can has no rainbows no you you do know
that none of these cans had anything to
do with Dylan Mulvaney
well it's almost like it's almost like
that manga is really stupid and they
always miss the mark yeah almost like
this guy would miss a 12 ounce
did you know that they
how [__] stupid they are all right so
Dylan Mulvaney for people who don't know
a a trans Tick Tock activist star
um got these cans special cans cans that
no one else got okay right that had
Dylan's face on it you're telling me
that bud light's not selling these scans
exactly so then Republicans are like I'm
gonna go buy these cans with Dylan's
face on it and they don't exist and then
I'm gonna throw it out and what they
found is that there are no cans with
Dylan's face on them the only thing they
have is like you know pro lgbtq
messaging where it's like hey I support
I'm this whatever it might be just it's
just words it's just [__] words
are they loud words are they allowed
but I'm sure Republicans think that if
it's on the can then the transit of
property like osmosis like all of a
sudden if I drink the can then I'm gay
kind of thing I wouldn't be surprised if
Republicans really do believe that
there's a woke gay
anti-vaxx potion inside these beers and
if you drink it you become this leftist
right brain of course that's of course
what they're scared of that's of course
what they're scared of or they're just
[__] let's see how this guy swings
let's see if he let's see if he connects
really well let's watch
horrible
that when okay as someone who played
baseball for many years many many years
through High School
uh look boom he loses contact you follow
the you follow when you swing when you
make it when you make contact never you
know [__] look at him blink his eyes
like a little [__] you never do that
you can take your eyes off the ball you
do not take your eyes off the ball you
continue to you swing through you don't
[__] let go of that out of your sight
[__] this guy what a [__] okay well and
then he and then he does this little
threatening thing with the baseball bat
he does the trump it was America maybe I
was promoting American-made bats I
wasn't threatening anyone let's watch
[Music]
stay the [__] away from our kids
when when were kids ever mentioned in
any of these [__] beer cats that's
what I'm telling you man that's why I'm
saying man they're focused on the
genitalia and the kids because it's all
projection you're like what does this
have to do with Tennessee and Jones and
Jones being expelled it's because it's
the same [__] over and over again it's
the same stupid [__] own the libs
we're a bunch of real America First Nazi
[__] that's all it is it's out now I
want to point out he says order online
Ultra right beer.com all right now I
want to show you because I'm not going
to go to the website but I'm going to
show you a um I'm going to show you a
screenshot here from
Ultra right beer.com this is the beer
can right that's not even the beer can
that he had by the way no well I mean
obviously they're they're trying because
my guess is if you ordered this it would
take like months to get it you want to
know what you want to know what I think
he's doing what's then I I would be
willing to bet a thousand bucks on this
that's how confident I am what he's
doing and you see it uh and I don't know
if that's how the final version of the
can will be I'm sure this is like a
prototype or a mock-up or something but
the can that he has actually with him
when he's in that commercial if you
notice it's uh it's one they're
wholesale cans that are purchased
but I wouldn't be surprised because you
can do this you can literally go on to
Google and you can say I want to buy
white label
you could do wine if you want right I
know you've done that print your face on
it you can print your own brand on for
like a party yeah like for a wedding a
lot of weddings will print like their
wedding stuff on them beer cans you can
you can sell the whole pack in a six
pack you could do a 30 rack an 18
whatever you want this is I guarantee
this is what he's doing he made a
website it's Drop Shipping white labeled
beer from some company and then I bet I
did it I bet Anheuser bush is bottling
this [__] what do you want to bet that
one of these woke queer beer companies
are the ones that are bottling this idea
I'm sure I'm sure they have some some
Brewery somewhere some Brewing facility
where they're like oh yeah we outside
yeah sure yeah it was like you have a
like I know people that have done it for
weddings anniversaries birthdays
whatever and they put their face they
put a photo whatever it is it's you
[__] pay someone to just fill a beer
can with standard ale lager whatever it
might be you pick it you name it and and
you know what you know what you know
what's funny is Anheuser Bush you would
think they'd be like no we're not going
to do this [__] this this is against
this they're like yeah hell yeah well
hell yeah we'll bottle this [__] for you
are you kidding me yeah so you're gonna
do this to against us but then we're
gonna bottle we're gonna make money
Azure whatever you want to do yeah and
the reason why it's they're buying the
gate the gay beer is in the can right
right is in the can it's a white it's a
white fragile male can but the beer in
it is woke you can't take the gay out of
the beer man it's already in it it's
already in it so here's here's a
screenshot from the website where you
can buy now again this is called
conservative day
what the [__] conservative dads Ultra
right beer what a horrible [__]
branding name for a beer I just had I'm
not gonna say it online because
someone's gonna take the idea I have an
idea for it okay another product save it
save it yeah um but this is a six-pack
folks for 19.99 and I'm sure that does
not include shipping and handling no
[__] way does that include shipping
and handling so my my assumption is that
you're right and your guess Gabe Sanchez
the reason why this [__] is 19.99 is
because they're charging him full price
to bottle or can it can this beer and
print his label on it and he has to sell
it for 19.99 which is eight bucks over
probably the price of about twelve
dollars so he can make a decent margin
so he can grip these dumb [__]
that are gonna buy this [__] Bud
Light that's packaged up in some [__]
white fragile male can for 20 bucks
six-pack good luck to you dumb
[__] add to add to add
stupidity to cart baby I want 12 of
these oh what the [__] are you kidding
me do you want to know oh my God uh okay
so for anyone who's interested do you
want to know
how long it will like when it'll be
available
so you're saying because I said it'd
take months to get it right so what are
they saying on their website how long
it's going to take for them yeah bud
wiser to to can this beer how long is it
going to take Budweiser to Candace they
said it's in production and it won't be
available to ship out and this is an
approximation which means it'll probably
be later than this also
uh
May 11th is when they will approximately
start shipping them out which means for
the next month
you're not gonna get [__] by the month
is going to go by and you're going to
get this [__] can on your doorstep in
like probably a couple months
realistically and you're gonna be like
wait what did I order again right you're
gonna No One's Gonna remember it the
other thing is
it's gonna be [__] skunk by the time
it gets to you it's because 100 they're
not gonna drop [__] the drop ship this
beer right whoever's buying me they're
gonna ship it in pallets to this
wherever this is okay look you know you
know Trump's water right water same [__]
it's just that well water doesn't water
doesn't Skype Trump might I don't know
right when you watch the Sylvester he's
just like I wouldn't watch my socks with
this
I guarantee one that he's doing this
white label drop ship okay which is like
a lot of people do it and it's an easy
way to make money uh
uh but it won't come out for another
month which is in production as the
website says which means there's some
facility somewhere they take the labels
and I gotta slap them on a bunch of uh
blank silver cans right and then
uh and then in a month from now they're
gonna start shipping them out and then
at some point in the near future after
that you know it could be a couple weeks
could be a month could be a couple
months depending on where you are
depending on where you were in the wait
list or whatever it is and if someone's
gonna get it at their house and they'll
be like I totally forgot I bought this
why did I buy this again
and then they're gonna drink and they're
like this tastes [__] gay
why why this tastes like why does it
taste like gay why is this like Bud
Light right this tastes like like gay is
that what you say man this this tastes
like gay yeah it's not it doesn't taste
good it tastes like it like I I could
easily see them like it's like
immediately because the package comes to
the front door they're making social
media videos and they crack it open
right away so it's not cold because and
I I doubt I doubt he has the
infrastructure or is willing to pay the
money to ship this thing there's like
unicorns tastes like [__] rainbows
man
no rainbows b-i-e on Twitch says tastes
like unicorns oh my God that just [__]
that just made me think of another idea
okay okay keep right keep writing them
but wow
our audience is the best in the world
here's James on YouTube he says gay ish
maybe maybe maybe George Santos will
will want them to have this as a sponsor
right he's like well they're gay-ish
right but if you have to remember the
timing of this right May 11th is when
they they come out of production
common comment on YouTube says translate
I'm writing that one down I think that's
gonna make a camera in this video I have
another thing about what oh my God I you
know you know because I'm gonna I'm
gonna let you finish on like The Tick
Tock of when these people are gonna get
this or not get this beer I should say
because that's probably going to be one
story that we're gonna see is this guy
this guy just grifting and he's gonna
get sued because he can't fulfill these
orders fast enough or some [__] I'm sure
we're gonna see this later on and we're
gonna probably do two minutes three
minutes on it later because we're gonna
remember this [__] that did the
commercial yeah but the craziest part
about all of it is that beer companies
and beverage companies have been
supporting all kinds of communities for
a long time because they sell beer to
everyone and hate does not sell anymore
it doesn't sell that's why this this
[__] set guy this [__] bonehead
with this this altaright Moga all white
beer that he's got he's gonna flounder
and it's gonna it's gonna [__] him up
probably and the reason why is because
you think Budweiser is scared of this
guy [__] putting out twenty dollar a
six-pack beer you're not you won't be
able to compete with Bud Light in the
long run you dumb son of a [__] Bud
Light owns inbev owns like
a really big percentage of the market
share number one number two they're a
huge multinational corporation who owns
Budweiser and they own brand after brand
after brand and you don't even know it
it's even hard for you to find out which
ones they own and which ones they have
owned which ones they don't own anymore
we went through that yesterday but it is
[__] it is [__] laughable that
this guy thinks that this is going to be
nothing more than a couple ten thousand
dollars that he's gonna make on a grift
until people are like what the [__] no
I'm not gonna reorder your [__] skunk
ass beer that showed up tasting like
[__] and and and it's probably it tastes
just like Bud Light anyways shitty ass
Bud Light come on man and I'm gonna pay
twenty dollars for a six pack get the
[__] out of here I can't even get drunk
on the six pack what's wrong with you
twenty dollars if you if you if you
think about it right like people who
this is you know okay this beer is a
novelty beer okay no one no one's going
on the website unless they're [__] in
it but then again who knows they're
Republicans and they're willing to give
their [__] their refinance their
house and put their mortgage up when it
comes to uh supporting Trump so who
knows maybe they maybe they will but I
can't imagine somebody going oh man you
know how I'm gonna own lives I'm gonna
buy 10 packs of this okay 10 packs
like these people who are going to buy
this novelty beer because that's what it
is it's 20 bucks for a can of standard
runoff beer from some Budweiser or or
Miller Coors or whatever it might be
it is runoff from the brewery saying
like oh yeah we got some extra [__] that
we'll just like whatever and I'm like
it's been sitting in the [__] tank
right now so it's good enough right but
like that's what it is like four
ingredients right it's it's hops I'm
borrowing this and that like dude I'm
sure there's more to it than you think
but also the idea that that somebody
because remember the timeline all right
so May 11 is when they approximately and
it's probably not going to happen then
approximately come out right of
production they start shipping it okay
what happens in June Tony
in June yeah what's in June well I I
what is in June pride month oh oh yeah
okay so pride month is June yeah so this
guy thinks hey you know how I'm gonna
own the [__] lips I'm gonna start
shipping this [__] out in May right
which by the way even before June hits
the marketing department the beer
companies the production facilities they
are ramping up to say we got all the gay
beer get ready for it we got rainbows we
got pro lgbtq messaging we got
Dylan Mulvaney on a [__] post or a
billboard we got uh gay people in a
parade drinking beer on billboards and
ads online and [__] YouTube and
whatever it might be these are the
things that are going to be coming out
at the end of May getting ready to
launch in June so this guy decided you
know how I'm gonna own the lives I'm
going to release a beer in May that's
pro pro right promaga Pro conservative
Pro bigot
anti-lgbtq to only be [__] trumped by
a gay woke ass beer that's gonna have a
whole month a whole [__] month to
celebrate that Community that's how
[__] dumb he is he said [__] dummy
you said trumped was that um yes it was
intentional oh okay okay good I I got a
few more uh names here let's see uh I
think I think uh we meant yee-haw yeaw
life
Ultra trans gay ale
this is the best one [__] ice
oh look at Gabe Sanchez he's like oh you
guys are right now she's a great I had
some other ideas there's one I mean it
dude the translate is a great one I
probably will come with ice that's
hilarious
are pretty good uh I've got some other
ideas on like what the side effects are
or what results of drinking these things
are you know uh yeah you finish when you
drink it you know I got all these ideas
you're gonna do it are you gonna do a
commercial okay we're definitely gonna
we're definitely gonna play it on the
show then now also while we're here on
Gabe Sanchez's Channel make sure to
subscribe so you don't miss the the the
the the incoming parody satire beer
commercial which I'm sure is going to be
oh my God which is likely to be in tough
competition with the non-satire non-
parody face plant that we just watched
but all this is interconnected game
changes it is all interconnected it's
all it is all interconnected uh
yesterday did you watch the video of
Justin Pearson being reinstated after
that Tennessee legislator had had the
gay beard tantrums and they expelled two
black members for being wild wild black
did you see Dr Carlson respond to that
get me that clip I'm gonna play the clip
here
moments after
um Justin Pearson and he was speaking
here
um after he was reinstated let's listen
to what he had to say
oh
[Applause]
well put that in your cuck beer can and
drink it then
oh my God uh here's here's another scene
um from Memphis because uh Justin Jones
the unique thing about Justin Jones
being reinstated the other day was that
he was reinstated in Nashville which was
just blocks away from the capitol so he
was able he was able to walk once he was
reinstated he was able to walk down the
street to the Capitol
um to to to be to be sworn back in as a
representative
um Justin Pearson doesn't quite have
that unique experience because he's in
Memphis which is a wow it's a ways away
from Nashville but they did March in the
streets with Justin Pearson here's
here's a video of that
[Music]
turn it around
I just want to point out here how many
people are actually marching down the
street with him I I want to be clear
about this this is way more support
showing up to reinstate Justin Pearson
in Memphis than what showed up in the
largest city of the world to support
Donald Trump when he was shamed publicly
by being arraigned on 34 felony counts I
I just want to point that out that
Justin Pearson's Crown is way bigger he
draws way bigger crowds than Donald
Trump let's continue
[Music]
so there you have it Justin Pearson's
I'm being uh he's gonna be was he sworn
back in today or did they swear him in
yesterday uh I don't know if that I
didn't see if they swore him in
yesterday yeah I I caught news I was
filming uh I was filming it what was
that actually at the time at which I saw
the the tweets go out that he was where
he was being reinstated yeah yeah
um I was I was I was watching it as it
was happening
um him being reinstated it was I mean
it's historic moments right like this
like these people thinking making social
media videos where they're shooting Bud
Light cans that don't have Dylan
Mulvaney or rainbows on them because
they can't find those games or making
their own beer for twenty dollars a six
pack his own in the libs listen while
they're doing that we're doing the real
work of democracy Justin Pearson Justin
Jones are doing the real work of
democracy in Tennessee and the reason
why they're doing is because they have
our voices behind them to do it that's
the reason why I mean yes they are
intelligent men and they care about
their country they care about their
states they care about their communities
it is obvious that these two are very
serious about policy it is obvious that
these two are very serious about being
lawmakers for the constituents that
voted them to be lawmakers
and they're doing that work all the
while fragile white men like Cameron
Sexton are stealing money from Tennessee
because they're lying about where
they're living and Kid Rock who has a
bar and John Ridge who has a bar in
Nashville just down from the capitol
just with within spinning distance of
the capital are shooting and talking
about gay queer beer and that's their
issue while Justin Pearson and Justin
Jones are are at crowds and crowds and
crowds of people who care about their
country who care about their communities
are crowding at the Capitol saying
enough's enough do something about gun
violence do something real and then and
that shows you how much Republicans care
slash really don't care at all because
what it is is they don't care to talk
about the kids that have the the three
children that died and the three adults
that died at the Nashville School the
Covenant elementary school right they
don't want to talk about it they don't
want to talk the only time they ever
brought it up was after uh uh Justin
Jones was reinstated
after he was expelled to be like oh well
guys look you know what we need to talk
about here is like we need to respect
the the decorum of of the chambers and
the laws that are there and if you if
you want to be unruly and you want to
speak out then this is the repercussions
but also yes we do need to acknowledge
the six deaths that happen on in
Nashville at that elementary school they
never talked about it until that point
until they [__] realized that they
ate [__] because Justin Jones was coming
back and Justin Pearson was on his way
back they released a statement to say oh
okay guys look yes six people died and
it was a tragic event but up until that
point they said [__] and that's why
those that's why those two and there was
potentially a third of Gloria Johnson
were going to be expelled because they
decided to speak out and actually
represent the voice of the people that
were outside those chambers chanting
students who were said we're fed up
we've seen this happen I don't want to
have to live in a generation where I go
to school for the fear that I'm going to
be shot right you go to grocery stores
you go to churches synagogues clubs you
go to movie theaters you go to Banks
funeral homes like none of these places
are safe and Republicans like yeah well
it doesn't really matter let's just put
and and [__] in in Kentucky you know
I didn't realize this until yesterday
but in Kentucky the gun that was used in
that shooting is going to be sold off in
an auction Yeah well yeah I mean well
they want to put that back on the street
right it's gonna be it's gonna be uh
sold into auction uh this month like
that what what kind of world what kind
of [__] up timeline do we live in
where where the the the the local
government or the police department say
uh you know what we actually can make
money off that gun because hashtag
capitalism like that's how [__] up
that gun
shot and almost killed and did it kill
the police officer that got shot in the
hand is he is he passing I saw it I I
believe he passed away yeah right so I
mean it shot and killed police officers
and they're like yeah [__] that we'll
just we'll just sell that thing well
it's it's
um
because there was there was one one
officer grazed and one officer was shot
in the head he was on the job the one
who was killed I believe had just been
on the force for like a few days yeah
for four days four days a rookie a
rookie officer uh it's it's an insane
to still hear Republicans say the good
guy with the gun and it's like well even
even the people in the bank who are
there to guard the bank right if
Republicans well they're not they're the
air the guard the money not you which is
really [__] up thing to say but that's
the reality I guess you know just like
police aren't legally obligated to
protect and serve you on the street
right
um and so when you see the good guy with
the argument it's completely debunked
when you're like oh they went into a
bank and there were armed security there
oh you wanted you know and then then the
police showed up and one of them you
know one got crazed one got shot one
died like the good guy with the gun
argument
fails every single time I mean you look
at Uvalde 400 police or like Law
Enforcement Officers showed up and he
was like we're not going in that room
well we're not going to go in that room
where you know I'm gonna wait till the
gunman either kills himself or kills all
of the people in the room and then we'll
go in right
it's I mean this is the [__] this is the
messed up timeline they're crazy well
and I'm going to show you this clip you
send me this clip of Tucker Carlson
talking uh about Justin Pierce and this
is only one I I watched the full segment
on this and holy [__] man he goes from
he goes Rachel uh dolezal or whatever
right remember her then there's uh then
he goes into just whoa he made some big
huge Loop yeah hold on he starts with
her to be like this is where the TR
because then he talks about or he starts
with transitions right oh
transition so then he goes into Rachel
dolezal and then he goes into Justin
Pearson and then he goes into uh he goes
into Obama Clinton uh Biden AO see and
talks about how all of these people like
as if just as if uh Tucker Carlson just
learned about code switching like he
never learned he never knew what that
was before that and so he's going to
talk about this in this two minute clip
but just know that the full segment is
like I don't know 15 minutes of him
going off on this racist rant well it is
Tucker Carlson so of course she goes up
on a racist rant before I get to this
video
um I want to remind the chat because a
lot of people are asking in the chat
what is hide and seek we are playing
hide and seek Thursday today maybe it's
peek-a-boo Thursday no no no don't say
peek-a-boo because that's what Trump
says oh yeah that's right and he tries
to use it against Tish James why was
racist I think we've come from racist
he's calling her racist on true social
racist animal all right well we'll get
to that here in a minute we'll get to
the Trump thing so let's call it hide
and seek Thursday right hide and seek
Thursday is where we go to another
YouTube channel and we broadcast from
that YouTube channel so what you do
is you subscribe to that YouTube channel
right now we're broadcasting from Gabe
Sanchez's YouTube channel so make sure
to subscribe here on Gabe Sanchez's
YouTube channel and here's also what's
gonna happen I actually have it
broadcasting to my channel and the
upstairs Channel private way in the
background you can't find it you can't
see it you can't find it so what I'm
gonna do after this broadcast is over
I'm gonna make those public so then the
show will be able to replay on our
Channel and the up buyers channel so
you'll be able to view it wherever you
normally do just the live broadcast in
the chat is here on YouTube is that Gabe
Sanchez's YouTube channel but we're live
on Facebook right now on minus touch
Facebook page and my Facebook page we're
live on Twitch and we're on Twitter I
think we're we're on mine and your
Twitter right now so
um so before we get to this clip I want
to explain what hide and seek Thursday
is maybe we'll start doing this like
once a month where we go to someone
else's Channel give them some support
bring the [__] fam over there show
them what a real chat's like what a real
life support independent content
creators right [__] hey man okay
let's uh watch what right one right wing
funded uh channels and media does here
let's listen to Tucker Carlson Putin's
little [__] and give it this whole this
whole segment is going to be it is I'm
already started writing uh last night
this is a what was that oh so it's gonna
be so you're definitely going to want to
subscribe here to you yeah yeah you're
going to want to get the breakdown
because holy [__] you're gonna get the
breakdown and you're gonna see the new
um beer parody commercial too so um
let's play Tucker's racist
Justin Pearson wasn't white that's
probably how he got into Bowdoin in the
first place but he did a fantastic
impression of it what a nice young man
has he considered the apprenticeship
program at Citibank what that was the
old Justin Pearson before yeah I'll find
the I'll find the cricket before his
transition guys
I'll find the clips they're like they're
like oh Trans people aren't just people
transitioning their gender they're
transitioning their race that's what
he's saying is that what he's saying
here kind of yep okay well let's
continue on the floor of the Tennessee
State House
all hope seem to be lost representatives
were thrown out of the State House
democracy seemed to be at its end
like the NRA and gun lobbyists might win
but oh that was good news for us I don't
know how long this Saturday in the state
of Tennessee might last but oh we have
good news folks we've got good news that
Sunday
comes
Justin Pearson has a dream that one day
on the Red Hills of Georgia everyone
will do exactly what he wants or else
face indictment by the Department of
Justice
what yeah no that's I'm telling you man
hold on play the next clip so this is
what came this is what came before it
what the [__] this is going to give you
kind of well I'm not even done with this
clip no I know at all all right so okay
so let me just paint a picture for you
in the next clip he'll bring up a clip
right so you want me to stop this we're
gonna go to the next room we can talk
about this one we can talk about this
one and just to show you because then he
jumps into he goes Biden AOC Hillary
Clinton Obama because again
the the thing that I'm dumbfounded by is
that is that Tucker Carlson again
just all of a sudden it's like he
discovered code switching right which if
people don't know it's when you speak
one way with the group of people or in a
situation and then you speak another way
with a group of people in a situation
and there's a lot in rural areas exactly
right right like and the reason why is
because like when you go back to your
area or your your place where you're at
you kind of pick up your accent as it
works exactly a lot of people are like
where are you from Tony what accent is
that I'm like I'm from Central Missouri
it's weird yeah it's weird here you
don't really have one but like you know
you you're with family you you will
right be more casual you're giving a
presentation you'll be more formal right
well the other thing too is like if
you're in a in a private room speaking
into microphone you're not gonna well
unless you're me you're not gonna yell
and scream into it right right but when
you're speaking to a lot of people in a
big room you're gonna be loud but this
only proves that these fragile white
males like Tucker Carlson are absolutely
terrified of loud noises and Loud Noises
is the fascist tonight let's let's see
what other
[__] he's got here
Justin Pearson has changed quite
dramatically as you can see he
transitioned oh my God he grew his hair
into the modern incarnation of Martin
Luther King Jr himself oh my God but
he's not alone he's even saying that
he's the Martin Luther King Jr now like
like dude you're you're saying it out
loud man do you want to guess do you
want to guess how many years so pull
that back up do you want to guess how
many years uh the the photo on the left
is to the photo on the right
I mean
um I'm gonna say eight
almost is seven okay seven years seven
years and in seven years I'm sure that
you changed your haircut your your
facial hair you changed the way that you
you wear your clothes or what clothes
you wear or however you present yourself
glasses no glasses I'm pretty sure
that one could assume that in a seven
year period right or six or seven years
that you're what is the difference here
because you're you're pointing out the
difference here right in this picture
between this this younger Justin Pearson
and when he's in college right but
here's the thing is the difference I've
seen other than he's a little older is
that the dude has facial hair and longer
hair he grew his hair out right what is
that the is that the train they don't
yeah so it's a transition of going from
this I speak like I'm selling crypto you
know what it is yeah you know what it is
you know what it is afros are uppity
that's what type of saying also it
Tucker Carlson doesn't like the way that
he talks oh well here does he get to
that ear I don't know if he gets to that
one yeah I think he might actually Okay
let's listen
you see this all the time everybody in
the Democratic party wants to be Martin
Luther King at this point even Joe Biden
who during the famous March on
Washington was enjoying the many
benefits of Life as a college student in
a racially segregated State now he's at
MLK they all are
but you got to ask yourself as long as
we're mimicking civil rights leaders who
died almost 60 years ago why not some
variety
oh Jesus Christ
Malcolm X why is that maybe because
Malcolm X didn't talk like a
sharecropper he spoke dignified Standard
English he was running a Shakedown
racket to fleece guilty white liver oh
God yeah this [__] guy man if you if
you're like hey how he can't go any
worse right oh you've been wrong yeah
he's going balls deep into the races
Justin Pearson to a [__] sharecrop
what the [__] man
it is likely it is likely because I
think Justin Pearson's his lineage and
his Heritage is from Memphis Memphis
Tennessee like that's where his family's
from it is likely that Justin Pearson
comes from sharecroppers and I don't
know what was the thing before
sharecroppers what was that it was
another s word
slavery oh my gosh yep that's what it
was yeah what a [__] dangling man and
just to give you the timeline like The
Tick Tock of this event right
he gets reinstated right just like hours
before that yeah it was actually I think
it was about two yeah so what happened
was
unless they have this whole segment
ready to go which you know or or rather
they were getting ready because they're
like either way yeah they're like the
vote's gonna happen so we're gonna go
either way right rather it was more
likely it was more likely that it was
going to go his way because the four
Republicans that were on the council
didn't actually even show up to vote
right
[__] ass [__] wow because they didn't
want to appear to lose in the room so so
that's so you have a room of writers
right and I'm sure I'm sure uh Tucker
cross is like no no not racist enough no
no no throw Malcolm X in no no say he
has to speak eloquently for me to
understand and acknowledge and respect
him right but that's I mean some girl's
like you know the the idea that who's
the elitist who's the elite yeah I know
who's the I don't know I don't know I'm
just I'm just asking questions I can't
say for certain right but it would look
like Justin Bieber is isn't it isn't it
likely that we should ask the question
who who is the elitist in this situation
who's the person that has to have
someone talk the way that they want to
talk especially a black man has to talk
it's white it's Tucker Carlson shouldn't
we know that if Tucker Carlson feels
this way if this is really the way he
feels I don't know let's listen Malcolm
X had self-respect so he despised guilty
white liberals and he said so he
believed in self-improvement he knew oh
Jesus Christ okay then well let's go on
this is another clip right so this is
the clip that came before it right so
this is setting up so he goes into
Rachel so this is set up to the setup to
it and he then he's gonna play the clip
from Justin Pearson at College when he
was running for class president okay
let's watch and keep in mind these are
white school in a white state so it's
going to explain why Justin Pearson
might speak the way he's speaking
so that people don't feel [__]
uncomfortable let's let's watch
Trailblazers the Pathfinders the Daniel
Boone's of progressive identity policy
Jesus Christ one of them is a man called
Justin Pearson Pearson has been in the
news recently for helping to facilitate
an Insurrection at the Texas
Insurrection
but you may not know what Justin Pearson
was like before his transition back in
2000 isn't it funny when um when two
black guys get loud and it's an
Insurrection and Insurrection is bad
yeah no we can't wait yeah you can't
have them no they're sealed and say this
is unacceptable listen here boy
right that really is what it sounds like
is that Cocker Tucker Carlson thinks
that this is an Insurrection and
insurrections are bad when a couple
black guys get loud in a chamber of a
legislator because God forbid you say
hey there's enough people dying from gun
violence right and uh we should care
about the children in the schools that
you guys so
no no we we can't we can't care about
children we have to worry about sex and
sniping we got to make sure the speaker
Sexton and his family get paid a snipe
and to live in Nashville yeah right now
we got to make sure in Missouri that
we're defunding libraries because who
wants to learn [__] yeah these Mass
bookings in these Mass dragons are
[__] out of control in this country
and by the way I want to point out the
only reason why Tucker Carlson has to
even research or find out who Justin
Pearson is in the first place let me
tell you let me tell you the reason why
you asked to do this is because of
speaker Sexton is a racist [__]
that's the reason why Tucker Carlson
even has to do this and it probably
pisses him off that he has to platform
Justin Pearson here on his show and he's
only making him into a a hero of the
left these lip charts love this guy yeah
because you hate him more than anything
let's listen 16 Justin Pearson was an
Ernest young student at Bowdoin oh so
now he's going after 16 years College in
the white estate in America a place that
cost 60 Grand a year for no obvious
reason a rich kid's school oh God damn
here's what Justin Pearson looked like
then as he ran for president of student
government he looks he looks like a he
looks like a young black man in a suit
gave Sanchez in this picture yeah he
looks but that's that's not okay Tony
yeah hey we can't have this person
actually have a uh looking nice with a
good outfit and a respectful job and a
career and aspirations and go to a nice
college and then I mean because what
what Tucker Carlson is arguing right now
is he saying that the only reason that
Justin Pearson got into that school he
black is because of his skin color right
that's why we expelled him because he's
black I mean it's because they're black
that's why they hate him that's why they
hate him they hate well they they also
hate the fact that God forbid a person
who's not white is successful in
something that white people thought they
could be successful in right right you
know it's like they're mad they're mad
that Justin Pearson went from being
being really successful at his college
running for class president and then
came out and became a state congressman
got expelled and then reinstated almost
just hours after right exactly they're
really mad they're like we're so mad
that our fascist suppression of your
voice and your work you're right as a
human
[__] backfired how dare democracy
that's why he made this whole segment
dedicated to Justin Pearson but then at
the same time was like well I'm just not
going to attack only Justin Pearson
we're gonna find a theme here we're
going to talk about how other
politicians might speak differently
based on where they are and who they're
talking to right
well let's let's see what else he's
some more vile that he pukes up here
I'm Justin J Pearson and I'm running for
president of BSG there are a few reasons
that we're running this campaign this
year one has to do with representation
how can we represent all voices in a
conversation I want to bring together
different voices dissenting voices
voices that may be more liberal or more
conservative in order that we can reach
a point of sort of the radical middle
for conversation and dialogue happens
and growth happens join the people's
Pearson campaign and let's chart
ourselves to a better future
foreign
together said Justin Pearson you know
that's what he's been saying the last
week you could easily imagine coming
from a Suburban orthodontist Justin
Pearson wasn't white that's probably how
he got into Bowdoin in the first place
but Jesus Christ the impression of it
what a nice young man as he considered
the apprenticeship program at Citibank
he's white he's just not white enough
it's the same [__] that you went through
when you're a kid right with this whole
oh my God you're you're not wide enough
you're not Mexican enough right I mean
you're in it you're in this weird you
you went to a white school but you're
black you're trying to be white but it's
that [__] man I mean people obviously
people's experiences are differently but
having to having to live where
in in a society where you're not one
enough of one thing and which means
you're not one enough of another thing
like the idea that people won't accept
you in either
is the same thing that Tucker Carlson's
doing right here he's like oh well the
only reason that he benefited to go to
this really nice school is because he
wasn't white right it's because his
black skin got him in as a diversity
project or whatever it might be and so
when you look at what's happening Tucker
Carlson exposed himself again as a
racist because there are many many
accounts there's a [__] timeline of
things that he said on the radio
[__] exactly right like he is a he is a
Nazi a proud boy sympathizer he's called
Iraqis
um he called them uh [__] monkeys he
called like all of these things that
Tucker Carlson has done right and of all
people Tucker Carlson [__] the
nepotism right Joker Carlson is a nepo
baby okay let's talk about yeah he's a
[__] nepho baby yeah come on he's
like a holistic Empire and people like
oh this guy you know pulled himself five
by his penny loafers you know that's
Tucker Carlson he is a racist bigot who
is jealous and envious
of other people who are not white that
are successful and especially because
he's like oh [__] this kid is Young got
a great [__] powerful voice that he's
using for a movement to deliver change
and I'm a weak bigoted to a cuck do you
want to you want me to give you proof of
why he's [__] wrong about the video
in college yeah you want me I'll give
you proof here this is Justin Pearson's
Instagram page the other day
um oh Judy's got pronouns man [__] this
[__] dude the other day when when um
when I when I discovered what was
happening in Tennessee
um Instagram knew that I was
um you said it out loud that's why well
no what happened was is I was liking
some of the Tennessee holler stuff on
Instagram so it so it gave me Justin
Pearson's Instagram page so I followed
him of course and I want to show you
this video of Justin Pearson this is not
of him in college this is not of him in
college in a white college in a black
college this is him just the other day
okay
and well if I could turn them down
let me [__] Instagram okay well we'll
just play it like this two of you who
stayed for over 12 hours to see the
proceedings of the State House that led
to the expulsion of myself
representative Jones but also the
keeping of Representative Johnson in the
state legislature from folks from
Memphis who traveled at 3am and 4 a.m
thank you today we talked previously
with President Joe Biden about what we
can do about ending gun violence and
stopping the tragedies like we saw in
Covenant and the tragedies in our
communities now we're getting ready to
meet and talk with vice president Harris
about the same thing that only happens
because of you because we remain
committed and focused on the issues of
ending on violence and our communities
and protecting one another so let me ask
you Sanchez does that sound much
different than that uh that uh ad that
he made in college the only the only
difference is he's got glasses facial
hair and an afro do you think you think
it's because
um the reason why he was speaking the
way he was speaking in the chamber is
because he was making a passionate
speech it's always here it's almost like
when you're doing a speech like like
that right you want to be poetic right
you want to amplify and you want to
emphasize and you want to express the
personality and actually have emotion
right empathy and say hey I'm sick and
tired because the other thing that
people need to realize is that that this
is a deeply personal issue Justin
Pearson lost a friend to gun violence so
this isn't just like oh run-of-the-mill
like it's another problem in America
it's I have an actual connection to this
and that's why I care so much about it
Stephen Carlson doesn't want to bring
that up obviously do you think Tucker
Carlson went out on Justin Pearson's
Instagram page to see if there was any
video that may made it
sounded the exact same I mean I'm sure
that Tucker Carlson I'm in case you
think I'm sure whenever they try to like
dig up [__] on people like oh you can
always rely on social media right I'm
sure they went there like no no can't
show this yeah well yeah they can't they
couldn't show this video next to the
video and then try the argument whoa he
sounds the same but he looks like right
he's got longer hair and he's got facial
hair I mean to be fair and and Tracy
says uh on YouTube that's an awesome tie
oh yeah I do have to agree this is a lot
better tie than the one he was wearing
in the college I mean it was the first
thing I saw when this is way better this
is a badass I like this day by the way
Justin if you if you watch this ever
that's a badass diet keep wearing ties
like that my friend not like the one you
were wearing a guy this is a way better
tie but here's here's a political Tea on
YouTube says same voice it's the exact
same because it it's it's um it's Justin
Pearson's voice it's his voice crazy and
when he's giving a speech in front of a
microphone in front of a crowd of people
he is going to have a different Cadence
he is going to have a difference in his
order about him I don't know I mean this
is me Gabe Sanchez can vouch for me
every day when I come to the show this
is me I'm very loud anyways but yes do I
am I a little extra on the show
Absolutely it's it's to keep you guys
entertained while you sit here and
listen to my dumb ass for two hours
every single day while we March through
and and take care of this fascism that
we have in our hand here but yes am I a
little extra yes but it is me just like
when when Justin Pearson is speaking
after he he's reinstated at the council
Ari speaking at the well
on gun reform something he's very
[__] passionate because he doesn't
want kids to just die needlessly at the
hands of [__] the gun lobby yes he's
gonna get passionate yes he's gonna get
loud yes his Cadence May [__] change
from time to time to keep your attention
you see how this works it's almost like
Tucker Carlson knows what performances
but he doesn't want to admit it with
Justin Pearson because if he would admit
it he would have to show how [__]
racist he actually is I don't know
because I'm sure I'm sure what we see on
Tucker Carlson is a performance right
I'm sure because you got to remember
that there was that video of that one
guy who who approached him in the bait
shop or the gun shop in Montana I think
it was yeah and Tucker Carlson he didn't
talk like this he wasn't asking
questions no he was scared like a little
[__] you know like he he was like oh
okay he's like okay okay
man back off man and so okay I have to
get you on vacation here man yeah you
don't need to come at me again well
you do not need to come at me like that
in this bait shop I mean I don't know
why I'm here we're here to buy ice and
unwoke beer
um so I I want to encourage everyone to
go over to Instagram if you had an
Instagram account and follow Justin
Pearson and follow him on all his social
media everywhere I have a feeling that
we're only getting the beginning of it
right that's that's the best because I
mean even look here's the thing seven
years ago he's at college and he already
has aspirations of a political career
he's running for class president right
he knows exactly how to pitch how to
talk to people what what issues are
important to students right and then you
transition that in seven years and he
says great I know my voice I know what I
want to say I know how I want to say it
I know how I want to deliver it to
people and I know what works
so when he's in the well and he's given
a speech or he's being reinstated on the
steps of the Capitol you know and he's
he's he's being sworn back in
he knows exactly how he needs to speak
for people to listen to feel it to get
the the chills or to get a reaction
right to not speak so fast that people
miss the point that he's trying to make
right to deliver the Cadence and
emphasize the point he's trying to make
and Tucker Carlson is a little bit butt
hurt by that and why say a little bit I
mean very butt hurt by that and very
triggered that there's a young black man
who has a long [__] career ahead of
him in politics well Tracy on YouTube
makes a good point here Tucker is scared
that Justin Pearson sounds like MLK
because that makes Justin more effective
and that's what they're really scared of
is effective activists effective
activist to communicate with people and
constituents that's what kellyanne
Conway was scared of the other day oh
these young people are gonna kill us man
you know what we're running out of time
here it's been two hours already son of
a [__]
and the reason why I'm mad is because I
had a couple more videos I wanted to
show one was in the Missouri uh Senate
the other day a Missouri Senator Mike
Mike moon is his name is that the 12
year old yeah he's like he's advocating
for 12 year olds and the reason why the
the reason why you know what [__] this
this yeah
show show how I'm going to show you what
your state is yeah let's go heard you
talk about parents rights to raise their
kids how they want in fact I just double
checked you voted no on making it
illegal for kids to be married to adults
at the age of 12 if their parents
consented to it you said actually that
should be the law because it's the
parents right and the kids right to
decide what's best for them to be raped
by an adult okay so if you're not if
you're not following here someone is
questioning Mike Moon a senator of
Missouri unlike Center in the southwest
part of the state Mike moon now Mike
Moon voted to make sure that 12 year
olds with their parental consent can
marry adults okay that's what he's
saying listen listen oh my God like you
would think Mike Moon would have
something just anything any kind of
argument besides the one he's gonna make
listen to this okay Junior kids who have
been married at age 12.
that was the law you voted not to change
it do you know any kids who have been
married at age 12 I I don't need to I do
and guess what they're still married
gentlemen Yo God that was not that is
not the take you want to have man God
damn he's like no you don't have any 12
year olds you had 12 year olds been
married no and the guy's like I don't
give a [__] how many 12 year olds have
been married it shouldn't be the law and
you voted for it to be law and the guy's
like well you know how many 12 year olds
are still married like oh my god dude
that's the reason why we're saying it
shouldn't be the law that parents can
give away their child to an adult so
they can marry them you would also not
only he goes oh you know how many
children have been married at 12 and
he's like I don't [__] care because
that's [__] gross well I know people
who have and they're still married yeah
dude that sounds how do you like get
married how do you like them pedophile
apples [__] like what how is that a dig
are you kidding me why do you think
that's a that's a weird [__] Flex to
bring on this conversation that you know
people that got married at 12 right like
you're like oh yeah this guy who was 20
married this girl who was 12. dude
please stop talking please stop it's
like the you know it's like the guy in
in Florida who talked about trans people
being mutants and demons and imps all of
these people
which by the way there's a what was that
on that that I'm working on right now as
well
right dude there's so much it's like
just like [__] fascist machine you
got guys shut the [__] up man just sit
just look look I know you guys you know
I know I don't want them to shut up I
want them to show who they are that is
what we really want isn't it I want them
I want to yeah but I mean yeah sure but
there's a point like
and okay so I have what was that and one
of the lines that I wrote in there that
I that I filmed is uh I was like hey
maybe next time we don't attack a group
that has been beaten down for years both
verbally and physically and next time
when they talk you sit listen and shut
the [__] up right because here's the
thing what the guy said this guy this
Webster Barnaby in Florida [__]
doubled down on this and was like wait
his name his name is Webster Barnaby
yeah oh my God I think a more
appropriate name is bigot Burnaby that's
his name I mean yeah did he was he born
with a white hood or what the I mean I
mean it's one of those people
yeah I'm sure if you asked him he'd be
like I've never experienced racism in my
life right it's like that one yeah I
haven't dude it's like the one guy doc
who's uh I think maybe I could be wrong
he's like Pakistani or Muslim I forget
what he is
but he's the one who uh Kumar I think is
his last name but he's the one who spoke
during the expulsion vote and was like
uh I've never experienced racism no
one's ever said anything to Rocket oh
[__] [__] dude they either said it to
your face and you blacked out or they
said the [__] behind you but I can
guarantee that a bunch of white people
probably the people in this room have
said [__] about you behind your back or
said it to your face and you didn't
realize it was racism because everyone
[__] laughed and you're like I Gotta
Laugh Too and and you're the victim of
this racism so when people like Webster
Barnaby who wants to who wants to call
Trans people X-Men which by the way
X-Men holy [__] man if I can be compared
to X-Men that's [__] awesome well
because you know it's been Fight Against
Racism and bigotry right though the
craziest part about the the X-Men story
is is that if you're gonna call Trans
people X-Men you're actually making them
into the um
Heroes yeah man that's weird yeah that's
weird that you would try to do that like
you would you would compare a group that
is is race coded and queer-coded already
right to then say they're mutants like
the X-Men okay that's a you're you're
not making the point that you think
you're making right now right and the
point that you're you're standing behind
is you're like Dr Bolivar Trask or
you're trying to be you're trying to
you're trying to yeah you're germinate
yeah a group of people who are different
first the first X-Men movie there's a
scene where uh where uh or uh Jean Gray
is presenting before a committee of
senators is a Committee hearing right
and one of the Senators that is the uh
if anyone's seen the first X-Men from
2000 you know exactly what I'm talking
about but he's like we need to know
exactly who they are we need to have a
registry sounds a lot a lot like
something else that happens
well it sounds like what's going on
right now in a lot of State houses
exactly but you know I can't end without
mentioning
um the Cheeto does q Anon or bringing up
the word racist I wish we could get to
all his [__] crazy ass lunacy post
over there on true social and I don't
know how long he's gonna be deposed
today by KISS James but how [__]
sweet is it on a day like today that
Tish James is May making this guy sweat
in a room somewhere oh my God because
he's like freaking out on true social
like oh she's a racist and are you a
racist animal wow right there's a lot of
things oh yeah yeah and I wish I could
get to all of it but we're running out
of time but the fact the fact that a
very powerful strong black woman is
making the fragile white man Donald
Trump that Cheeto dust q and honor
lunatic absolutely sweat his [__]
head off because he didn't know what he
can and what he can't say without
incriminating himself in a room
somewhere is absolutely
if we remember if people go watch the
last opposition that happened in
was it the end of 2022 December yeah I
think it was it might have been or
January I forget when exactly but in
that video there's the beginning intro
right where they're like hey she's she's
like uh I'm I'm Tish James I'm the
Attorney General I precise I proceed
over the the you know the great state of
New York Donald Trump right and all of
these other times he's always like oh
Tisch James she's a racist animal blah
blah blah blah all this [__] right
he says it in front of a rally he says
it online but when he's face to face
with uh attorney general Tish James and
she's probably like I don't know more
than three feet away at the side of the
table be like hey we're gonna ask you
some questions please silence your phone
little [__] uh and we're gonna go
through this okay and he goes I guess he
goes
and just [__] smiles and nods and
that shows you exactly who he is weak
ass [__] weak [__] so I can't
wait for the new footage to come out
because it's gonna be great you know
what's also great
our audience is the greatest audience in
the world you guys followed us over here
to Gabe Sanchez's Channel I knew you
would do it I was very confident and
hide and seek Thursday what we did today
here's what we did today if you're
watching this on replay or you're not
you're confused why you're in the chat
on Gage Sanchez's channel is we came and
broadcast from Gabe Sanchez's YouTube
channel so make sure make sure right now
right now that you subscribe to Gabe
Sanchez's YouTube channel go to
youtube.com I am Gabe Sanchez if you're
here right now hit the Subscribe button
also do us a favor if you're not
subscribed to the Tony Michaels podcast
if we picked you up from Gabe's Channel
make sure to go over and subscribe to
the Tony Michaels podcast we'll be there
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
also download every single episode of
the Tony Michaels podcast on Apple
Spotify and Google it's 399 over there
on all the directories make sure to
follow us on Twitter at Tony Michaels
pod we're going to be doing the bonehead
of the week pole bone hand of the week
you'll be able to vote you'll be able to
vote for bonan a week on Twitter and on
the Tony Michaels YouTube channel so
don't forget to subscribe over there
follow us on Facebook as well at the
Tony Michaels if you're on Facebook go
over to the up wire and follow us on the
upward subscribe to the airport Channel
we broadcast from there as well God damn
what an episode hide hide and seek
Thursday tell us what you guys what the
[__] is going on Shake it out he's on
his channel so he's acting like a fool
yeah I'm just giving people a little bit
of fun
and they go man that was a great episode
I'm so glad I listened to Tony and Gabe
every day because if not I'd be kicking
walls and punching holes through [__]
racism which hey if you want to do that
slowly cool too but
this is a great spot to get some you
know cathartic release that's right
laugh it off make fun of these people
mock hours a day call them out get
educated right you know and and you know
play our queer beer commercials everyone
come back tomorrow we're gonna be same
time same places you know where we're at
we're on all the YouTubes and the
twitters and the Facebook don't miss us
same time same place tomorrow Surf's Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] em [__]
[__] them
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon